どうも （ﾁｬﾁｬﾁｬﾁｬ）えー
遊戯王とモンハンで
最近くそ忙しい (^_-)
皆さんコップで飲み物入れるとき氷ってよくはいってますよね
もちろん家で飲むとき氷とか入れないと思うんですけども
何かマックとかスタバにやっぱ氷ってはいってるんですよ、
と言うことで基本的に飲み物を何かで飲むときは
氷は入ってます！！ということで今回はこちら
とうぜ人生はいたずら！
虫が入った氷
1.カープに飲み物をいれ虫が入った氷をこっそり入れてください
２.友達に”飲める？”ってあげる
３.飲み物飲めるその瞬間の友達の顔！想像するだけで楽しいでしょ？
なにかといいますと　見てわかる通り
虫がはいってるんですねよ
虫って言うのがあれなんですよね
氷の中に入ってる（ｷﾘｯ）いやこういうのよく思い付くよ
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
うわこれ やだな～～～～
ぱっと見本当に氷に虫が入っているようにしか見えません
なんでこうゆうのって無駄にリアルなんだろうなー
いやｗｗこれはいやだな～～～
一回普通に入れてみましょう
それにしてもうまい！
まずジュースをなみなみと入れてよきサイズの氷をいれてゆく～～いれてゆく～
はい、でその氷の中に虫のやつをいれてゆく～
うわ～～～～～
これ、びびるな～結構怖いっすよ
すーごいっすね何気なく入っている　氷の中に
うわ～～～～～～～～
うわっ！！！！！
これやだな～普通にびくってなりますよｗ
う～～ん　うまいんだけどねｗ
はいっ　というわけで、今回は、もし氷の中に虫が入っていたらドッキリです
いや～～～～普通にいやでしょｗ
なんかさあんまり氷の中まで気にする人はいないと思うんで～
さすがにこんなね～氷の中まで見ることは無いと思うんすよね～～
一番ベストなタイミングで、まさきジュース飲む♪ってこうやって行って
コップ準備して、何気なく氷入れてるふりをしてる中にこっそりと虫の氷を入れて
まさきがありがとうって言ってこうやって貰って
飲む直前で、、、、
(まさきが虫に気が付く)
いっ！！！！！！！！
あ、こぼれちゃった
ﾌﾟﾙﾙrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr(発狂)
ってなるのが一番理想なパターンです。
ではやっていこう
-bgm-
限界感じた
でもレアリティこそ力
まあ確かに
はじめ「デッキ持ってきた？」まさき「持ってきた」
はじめ「今日、そっち持っといてもらってもいい？」
まさき「全部？」
はじめ「してないよｗｗ」
はじめ「大丈夫×２」
まさき「え？なんかなんかなんか入ってる\\も～～～」
ぽーぽぴぽぴーぽー
ぽぴぴぴー
はじめ「気付くのはや～～なんか俺の理想では、ありがと～～って（口元で気が付く）ここらへんで気が付く予定だった」
まさき「ぢゅふふふふｗｗ危機感がなんか」（ｼｭｯ）
はじめ「はやいな～～」
はじめ「持ってってみよう　彼は多分気付かないと思う」
友達「わ！！それはもうなに？」
まさき「りんごジュース」
友達「いや、いい」まさき「いや、なんで？なんで？」
友達「いいです×２」
まさき「りんごジュースだってもうｗｗ」
一同「ｗｗｗｗちがうよ」
友達「うわ（パニック）びっくりした～～蜘蛛やん　びっくりした～」
はじめ「それそれ～～～～～」まさき「リアクション王じゃんw」